San Sebastian is known for its culinary
specialties for its gastronomic
societies and its strong women but
something I don't think those things
make for a good mix which is why many
cooking clubs only allow men to become
members the renowned club I'd sake is
one of them getting together with
friends gives you a boost you can talk
and they'll listen it's better than
going to a psychologist here you can
heat and talk and they don't need to pay
for a psychologist
every Friday shame I'll bet he meets up
with his friends at the clubhouse today
we're cooking cod cheeks baked cake and
mussels with tomato maitake has 120
members and a long waiting list to join
people cook in groups on different days
members can bring friends and split the
costs women can be invited as guests
well here they could come sits and
indeed lunch here every day if they want
to a club member repairs the food and
serves it to them comida he said we
women are allowed everywhere except in
the kitchen that's a no-go area amen
women can eat meals here but not prepare
them are they too distracting pretty
much so it's strictly men only in our
statutes we clearly decided that women
cannot be members at least not in this
club a special fear is enough aware
sexism its gender discrimination but
things don't have to be that way at
they're better better cooking club men
and women cooked side by side
Carmen Diaz has been a member for years
she also conducts research into gender
studies at the university of the basque
country who's the boss here everywhere
mixed clubs men and women have no
problems working in the same kitchen
they're teasing and wisecracks are often
par for the course
there's Benghazi impose this mania for
distancing yourself from others is
troubling men here women there why do
they need to be exclusively male domains
exclusive anything much Bellino's new
cooking clubs are springing up and
slowly things are changing but many
traditional ones don't intend to let
women in fade away no yo creo que yes
they have their own language their own
camaraderie and want to be among their
own kind they don't want to be disturbed
by having a woman around when they're
discussing certain topics is that on the
theatres timicin
the old cooking clubs were founded by
fishermen back then men sailed the high
seas and women kit for the children
these days there are a few fishermen
left and the world's men and women
inhabit aren't so separate anymore club
members no longer catch the fish they
cook but some still long for the day's a
much men were the breadwinners and women
stayed at home so once a week these men
get to have it their way I spend time
with friends and I get out of the house
we drank talk and no one's controlling
us we're among ourselves
jeez I'm sitting next to a banker and a
labor fellowship equality of the sexes
has no place at this table we're
different we behave differently not
better and not worse that's the way we
are if that sounds macho then we're
macho's it's how much is that that kind
of attitude worries come and yes it's my
law we face it's bad it replicates a
society based on masculine power which
makes it harder for women to achieve
equality owned a while does my sucky is
keen to sweep such concerns under the
rug maybe that little wonder as I sake
means excuse or pretext